those other kinds of bogus proofs that
come up let's just run through this one
quickly here's the fact that you know
about roots of polynomials every
polynomial has two roots at least over
the complex numbers over C and how do
you prove that well you just write down
the formulas for the roots you know the
quadratic formula one road is a minus B
plus this square root of square root
this quantity over 2a and the other root
is minus B minus this square root of b
squared minus 4ac over 2a and that's the
end of the proof you can just plug in
this formula for r1 into this for X into
this polynomial and it would simplify to
be equal to zero which shows that this
is a root you could plug that one into
this formula for X and simplify
algebraic when you discover it with zero
proving that r2 is a root we just proved
that every polynomial has two roots well
that's not true we haven't proved it
this is a proof by calculation that has
problems what's the problem well let's
look at a counter example what about the
polynomial zero x squared plus zero X
plus one it doesn't have any roots it's
just the constant one and which never
crosses to the origin so it's got no
Rhodes
what about a zero x squared plus one X
plus one well that's a 45 degree line
the X line um and the y equals XY and it
only crosses the origin once it has only
one root what happened to the two
formulas r1 and r2 and the answer was
that in this case we had it divided by
zero error if you look at that formula
um there's a quotient visit the cod
denominator of two a divided by zero and
these formulas don't work right they
aren't the roots and so implicitly in
order to have two roots we need to
assume that the denominator a the
leading coefficient of the polynomial is
not zero so that fixes those two bugs is
that all
well no because look at this polynomial
of one x squared plus zero X plus zero
has one root the only possible root of
this is zero because
you look at this the only way to get one
times something plus zero to equal zero
is if the something is zero so there's
only one root and what's going on here
well what's happened is that in this
case the two formulas are one in our two
which were different formulas evaluate
to the same thing when B is zero and C
is zero and a is 1 and that's why they
look like different formulas but they
evaluate to the same thing so there's
only one root the fix to that is to
require the quantity by which the two
root the formulas R 1 and R 2 differ to
be nonzero and that's the quantity that
you were taking the square root of the
discriminant is called b squared minus
4ac needs to be 0 and then R 1 and R 2
will differ and we will get the two
roots now there's still a complication
it sounds like we've now verified that
indeed our proof by calculation is
correct now that we've put in these
qualifiers that a is positive and D is
nonzero but what happens if B is nonzero
but negative it's an interesting
complication then let's look at the
formula x squared plus 1 where B squared
minus 4ac is going to be minus 3 and
that will turn out to have two roots
namely I and minus I and it's not
possible to tell which is which r1 is
taking the square root of minus 1 and r2
is taking the square root of minus 1 on
one of them adding the square root of
minus 1 the other one subtracting the
square root of minus 1 but which square
root of minus 1 there's no way to tell
the difference between I and minus i
abstractly they both behave the same way
and so we have an ambiguity about which
one is our one which one is our two
doesn't hurt at all for the theorem that
r1 r2 are different and so there were
two roots but ambiguity can be
problematic and let me give you an
illustration of that when there's
ambiguity I can do things like proving
easily that one is equal to minus one
here's the proof and I will let you
contemplate that
try to figure out just where in this
reasoning that step-by-step seems pretty
reasonable and but nevertheless I've
concluded that one is equal to minus one
which is absurd it's taking advantage of
the fact that you don't know whether the
square root of minus one means all I
ever - on so the model of all of this is
that first of all be sure that you are
applying the rules properly there's a
assumption of an algebraic rule in there
that isn't true and again that kind of
mindless calculation is risky when you
don't really understand what you're
doing don't have a clear memory of what
the exact rules are so it's
understanding that bails you out of this
kind of blunder let's look at one equals
minus one a little because it lets us
wrap up with an amusing remark what's
terrible about one equals minus one well
it's false and you don't want to ever
conclude something that's false that's
worrisome it's disastrous when you
conclude that something is false let me
give you an illustration of why because
let's suppose that one is equal to minus
one and that's a reason but in a correct
way from that assumption that we have
falsely proof but let's assume that we
start off with the assumption that one
is minus one well if I multiply both
sides of an equation by the same thing
it's equal so I can multiply both sides
by 1/2 and I get 1/2 is equal to minus
1/2 now I can also add the same thing to
both sides that's a perfectly sound rule
for reasoning about equality if I add
three-halves to both sides i've turned 1
equals minus 1 into 2 is equal to 1 now
I'm in great shape to prove all kinds of
things here's a famous one since I and
the Pope are clearly too we conclude
that I am the Pope or one that is I am
the Pope and I've just proved you this
absurd fact this is a joke that's
attributed a witty remark that's
attributed to Bertrand Russell the
famous philosopher and logician pacifist
Nobel Prize winner who supposedly was
approached by some socialite the party
who had heard that mathematicians
thought that if 1 is equal to minus 1
then you could prove anything
and so she challenged
prove that you're the Pope and
supposedly Russell who is a notoriously
quick wit came up with this example who
knows whether it's true it's a good
story
there's a picture of the great man and
you might care to learn more about this
remarkable contributor to logic and
philosophy and politics